mary mcaleese is unlike any other former
irish president
she grew up in northern ireland a
catholic living in a protestant area in
the violent seventies
her family forced to move out as
sectarian conflict grew
the irish war of independence from
britain between 1919 to 1921
had led to the partitioning of the
country and the birth of northern
ireland
exactly a hundred years ago thousands of
civilian lives were lost
in the intermittent conflict that
followed mary mcaleese
is calling on protestants not to mark
monday's centenary
with triumphalism language that is used
is so important to be
to use language that that doesn't other
the people that you share the island
with or you share northern ireland with
but language that shows that you're
sensitive
to their concerns one word the right way
can you know it can open people up and
it can make them it can soften hearts
whereas one word the wrong way
and you can harden hearts some are using
the word celebration
that is a difficult word and so for very
for most of the centenaries that we have
been through
we haven't used those words we've used
the word commemoration
we've used softer words we've used words
that open up to inclusion
and that understand that there are some
for whom
this was a tragedy and not a win
some feel it's ironic that the centenary
comes at a time when irish unity is
edging back onto the agenda
helped by brexit that puts an eu trade
border in the irish sea
separating the uk mainland from northern
ireland
protestants fear alienation the
government here in dublin sees irish
unity as a distant prospect
officially at least could it happen
sooner rather than later
well there's a growing body of opinion
that it could do you will never solve
the problems of northern ireland
by violence the good friday peace
agreement recognized something that
fighting couldn't achieve a referendum
on irish unity
dependent on catholics becoming a
majority that's likely to be confirmed
in a new uk census
then britain decides if there is a
referendum
this is the birthplace of irish
democracy and there's another factor
brexit took northern ireland against its
will out of the european union so for a
lot of center middle ground people
a united ireland is the only route back
to the european union and the advantages
which they enjoyed as european union
citizens and many young people in the
south support reunification
and want their leaders to put more
emphasis on achieving it
i think that the planning and
preparation for us should be begun
immediately to mitigate some of the
damaging impacts of brexit particularly
and what we've seen with southern
political leaders a lot of the time is
putting it on the long finger and
pointing to some indiscriminate date in
the future but irish history with all of
its overwhelming violence
may be the biggest obstacle for now on
both sides of the divide
many feel reconciliation still has some
way to go
andrew simmons al jazeera dublin